[Music]
oh hell
no you move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
bee Regina George don't look her in the
eye you could be really hot we changed
like
everything welcome to health and human
sexuality we'll be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
you're never going to believe what I
found this morning your burn book mom go
make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah
do you like gum sure oh no I don't have
any I was just you're a mess we will
help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
that is shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break
[Music]
who wrote all this
junk K pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't even
see it like a face
breast incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel
Noel no
[Music]
be gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
Umpa Lumpa an OA what now in fact in
Lumpa land I am regarded is something of
a Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed a tap
up inventor may I present Willy W's wild
and wonderful wishy-washy WKA Walker
please don't make me say that again and
chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world ooh he's good too good and anyone
can afford them even the the poor he
doesn't like it when people say poor
send Wonka a message do not sell
chocolate in this town you're going to
get more than a bon on the head hello
the B on the head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhist give them the old one
two I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course
run away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
not in
PRI good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forgetting very
well
huh you did it again tell me what it is
or I shall poke you quite viciously with
a cocktail
[Music]
stick
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever been with
a please no ow it's so hot it's really
hurting you deserve to be seen with
somebody is
Say whenn Never John bury me and cheese
oh I apologize in advance the eating
you're about to see will not be pretty
and if you have young children this
would be a good time for them to leave
the room you never
nobody hey Junior this is fck my father
you ever jumped a train I've never
jumped here's I stop really
where
[Applause]
oh OD you think he'd see that coming
let's get it I deserve to
be hey head of the wedding of my sister
yes I am so where's your fiance wait is
this him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass
on your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smelled like insecurity
nothing nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this girl
is a
[Applause]
disastrous we been our wedding
sorry is it going stranger what's going
on over there they dated she crushed his
heart that man does not have a heart no
way honey look who's here who is this my
ex Jonathan my parents have been trying
to get us back together he's like a son
to us maybe we should just tell everyone
we're together what it would solve that
problem for me and you clearly want
Margaret she seizure with me she wants
what she can't have there's no way we
can convince anyone we actually like
each other you know I still think about
that night we spent together shut up no
I'm
serious no matter how it ended it's
still pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do
it
here he is oh no I'm with Ben so is it
like we just got together or we been
saking around let's just be affectionate
show time permission to put my left hand
on your right buttock granted not a
magic
lamp hey little guy God damn
iton we have to kick it up a not nice
touch nice TR oh no no it's going to be
when are you ever going to learn it
it's
fine me are they watching are they doing
Titanic they're gone show's over oh my
God you have a mo or something on but
no what
the the what the one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
it it's
fine in three 2 1
[Music]
action so good good good good sh the
heart
[Music]
andad name anyone but him I didn't
approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on us I want
to see slap the out of you I really
could and I'm open to that in a safer
environment
you in a ghost no phone call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profession
profession is my middle name you said
your middle name was
Danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
holstered it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back B Jody's movie is dead why me
you're a stump man nobody's going to
notice you that's your job no offense I
mean some taking you find Ryder save
Jody's film you get the love of your
life back I'm not the hero I'm just the
double not today you're
not Tom we need you back on set
pal dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail
he was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason Bor
the they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you can make it
you can make it you can't make it it's
too dangerous got stairs okay
okay what happened to you face you look
terrible you look
amazing
you fall down you get right back up how
far would you go for the one that you
love how about you drink when this is
over engage your
core Yeah
Boy what are you doing later want to go
to a beach somewhere drink a spicy
margarit make some bad decisions
yes the heart and your
[Applause]
to everybody listen this is important
I'm going to show you guys something and
when I show you what I'm going to show
you don't freak
out I can
explain it's It's Beginning to Look a
Lot Like Christmas high stakes as
neighbors compete for best decorated
house on the Block I think this is the
house to
beat wow what's your Christmas
wish I just want to win this
[Music]
thing I'll take
it signature please ignore all the fine
print it's like you're signing your life
away Merry Christmas yeah Merry
Christmas oh it will
[Laughter]
be rise and shine Naughty Boy
what the hell is all of
this something's happening good morning
sir are you real we all were until we
fell into that elf sck
trap you made your wish you're in it now
I didn't sign on for this you literally
signed on for this you got to read the
fine print man the terms of service are
brutal say goodbye to your
dad why are yall just like
Prince
we are not going to let her turn your
dad into one of those weird Happy Meal
toys no offense I'm sorry n taken a
little
taken we are the
Carvers we got to catch an
elf you met with the wrong
family we should split up what do you
mean we should split up have you never
watched a horror film if you split up
somebody dies have you ever died oh it
is not fun that's true I'd never died
but Mom knows I didn't know you die
before let's go find these
[Music]
Rings is that who I think it is oh my
God Black Santa I knew Santa was black
[Music]
man oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size four rest huh how you so big the
big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my
kids
out clean up on I six sorry about the
mess hold
on oh hey Bo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy oh God we're going
to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip St collaborate and list with
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please C in
everybody I want him
f
what was that little pothole Maxi's been
up the whole time by the
way wish
that before I met your mom I was a cover
assassin I escaped at life and now they
found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this is my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait
[Music]
wait new
record
[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your
mother ah
that is not your mother look it we're
trying to get to Jamaica it all so
simp don't worry Chum's got you so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought your name was Chum yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
Len Chum what did you just call me I'm
sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
[Music]
what this isn't about migration it's
about
Adventure W Who whoo wo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what
dange it's you with larange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we
when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm kidding
kiding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
[Applause]
go I'm telling you it's going to be
another hot one out there in fact there
are heat alerts in effect for New Jersey
feeling like
100°
[Music]
through leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear ducts freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
come onc
me
made Diane meet the tailor you've done
well there old man I thought she was
your Cara yeah it's nice to see you too
gu listen J I think this one's your lot
well we were going to the same place I
told them take the first one we can just
follow in the one B by Jeff you're
joking
right bloody hell bloody
hell I'm sorry but who on Earth would
book to stay in a place like this B shaf
shaf B it's almost
right I have got an incredible sense of
deja vu and've got your suitcas here H
we
realized she'll take you to Hotel shter
no no way I don't want very happy
whenever I think about the future I H be
here what's upington oh my God my two
favorite people in the world what are
the chances yeah the J I think I know
how to get down a ski slow she knows how
to stop I don't think she knows how to
stop h no you're going to pop the
question for
Christmas
all
[Music]
right please stop worrying about bees
this isn't about bee this is about me
and you and what happens outside of the
bubble that we've created for
[Music]
ourselves I don't think there's a man
out there who truly deserves to marry my
daughter why don't we bring a bit of
mfield Christmas
[Music]
here
we are meant to be you know
[Music]
that there's no for mirales and I
believe it's your Christmas to me a s to
Rudolph let's
[Music]
fly there's a young
man I talk to him I wish I just met
you
[Music]
that's really weird
Lisa I'm the
greatest god
cre Taffy says it's a waste of time to
try and fix up way it's better just
accept a guy flaws that's so
cute
[Music]
I can't do that not until we bury the
body I can't be
saved and in the next life they'll
remember me remember
me
[Music]
you
remember really hope this goth phase in
soon
deith you foxy ass old
carry
on you really are a trixy old
[Music]
and you're sad stinky in the end I
think it's just
jealousy I think we know who it is love
my neighbor and I tried but I'll get you
in the ball she's henus Edith I didn't
do it I believe you may be charging an
innocent a woman police officer oh look
a flying pig I've got a daughter at home
why would I risk it all you want
in the nose holes you old beetle beetle
right if you meddle in my case these
will be on your
wrists in prison Rose may find some
Kindred Spirits in prison no no not the
murders or the rapists I'm thinking more
the drunks and the queers maybe just
trying to find a bright
side he you D all slippery or
Dodger why would I send a letter when I
can just say
it I probably say they you look like
Queen Victoria shoved a
netop or a I don't know
you s come and and the CES you make
look like they B out some sh
ass
better I have a
plan of will catch them in the
ACT what would your husband think my
husband isn't a live R so he's not
thinking a great
deal I like you Rose I ha
you don't like the idea of me leaving
this house do you I'm going to lose her
we're not standing for it I had one now
everyone is going to
know it's
[Music]
German pay attention fool you're about
to see what it means to be a hero you're
the only one who can save me I can't
take any more pities in the face I'm
tired of being rescued I want to do the
rescuing I'm
done are you going to tell me what
you're up to I am going on a quest to
make something of my life I gave him 45
minutes
tops I know you you're the dude from the
play who keeps catching p in the face
I'm DJ doggy
dog
there's something seriously wrong with
this
[Music]
guy why are you smiling we've got to sa
the baby raccoons DJ everyone loves baby
raccoons I can't go rescue them the plan
is to improvise that's not a plan on
word I can't it
[Music]
wet your imagination makes you move
mad
yeah a mighty
whale this was a bad
idea I'm your friend grab my hand and
trust
me DJ doggy Rhymes you catch if we rap
battle I'll win the match when I see
your turntable I always
scatch
I certainly hope you dance as well as
you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I we're not so different
agent
our little help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
[Music]
copout whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what do
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here here we
go I love this
book come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
happened and you kicked a hornet's nest
you didn't even know existed I'm in some
really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
cat
[Music]
to it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
God the great Adrien monk for watch
there you were solving a major case
every week I couldn't have done it alone
I could have but it would have taken
longer I have traumatic symptoms
unprecedented in psychiatric
history he's afraid of heights it's his
second biggest fear after germs actually
it goes germs needles Birds then
Heights that was no accident he was
murdered you have to help me turn turn
it turn it turn it there's a bomb I know
there's a bomb you're not
working we should leave a
note when Co hit I was in bad shape this
is
mine look at us everybody's you they're
going to hate it here's what happened so
how does that feel to be working again
like riding a
bicycle I'm glad to hear that I mean
it's
[Music]
terrifying how did you come to write
this book what really struck me was that
too few books we about my people where
are our stories where's our
representation would you give us the
pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shir girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they published look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses
it i' be standing outside in the night
de' be dads rappers crack you said you
wanted black stuff that's black right I
see what you're
doing we sold the book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee
can't use his real name is this based on
your actual
life yeah you think some ass
college boy can come up with that
no no no I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies your books Chang people
lives they're offering $4 million for
movie rights yes the Dumber I behave the
Richer I
get this has gone too far stag Arley is
still on the run for authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you wish I could go back to not selling
books is it bad to cater to people's
taste people want to love you mon you
should let them love all of you there's
already so much Buzz because of the
movie deal Michael B Jordan is circling
we want to put him on the cover in one
of those um scarves I guess you would
call them tied around his head a doag
doag that's it doag and a tank top with
the muscle showing something called the
fire
[Music]
department we're thinking we can get it
out in
hun
night what's up roomie
get ready it's Christmas Eve have you
been good last year not exactly naughty
but definitely gross for the naughtiest
have I ever shed you
wrong a bunch of times nicest what could
be better than being snowed in with your
family for the
holidays Limpus I think my freckles
might have frostbite do not make eye
Conta Christmas ever read about this
family that got Snowden and to survive
they had to eat each other
stream on Disney plus Del friendo is one
of Santa's most important Scouts it's a
liive Ry come on Diary of a Wimpy Kid
Christmas Cabin Fever streaming on
Disney
plus what on the street is your
daughter's coming home best she all no
style don't talk about my daughter man
don't look at her I'm sure your dad's
going to love you bringing home a gringo
boyfriend everyone knew his daughter
loved her new man a lot my dad loves
surprises I hate
surprises got to stay sober this
[Music]
year but not everyone knew I have a
surprise for you Mom Dad this is my
boyfriend your boyfriend OAS your
Sanchez puppy did not family meeting in
the Mexican home right
now what are you doing here I would like
to ask for your daughter's hand in
marriage Mr Sanchez from the director of
From Prada
Tanada I wanted a Brown
Christmas not a white Christmas I wanted
a traditional
Christmas Dad how come you never liked
any of my boyfriends what about ja yet
it'sin Mario Lopez hey throw me a bear
claw hey fool you diet remember he's
smart he's got a good job damn he's
handsome and is gay he's gay is
[Music]
gay I think I straight my back slow down
I know what I'm doing I got this this
way
okay don't you think you're overreacting
a little bit your father doesn't like me
he just needs to get to know you time
for you to play the game of the Gods
this a very dangerous game so you're
going to have to follow my
le because this Greeno right here I've
been humiliated in front of my family
not on my Christmas the party was whack
full we weren't
invited he asked you for Claudia kind of
marriage okay this is a season to be
married not to get
married check it out he's MadAss
something I'm mad at your mom for having
you what do you think red white and
green D It's Christmas not may Jesus was
Mexican it was my job to protect my rose
Christmas was for
family
[Music]
everybody how the Greeno Stole Christmas
Christmas ain't over yet eh Merry
Christmas don't smoke it
[Music]
everybody
he